hey guys it's Jenna here so if you have
been working out at home and you were to
keep your worker interesting well
introducing a chair to your workout
would definitely up the intensity it is
a really simple piece of equipment which
you can use to get you sweating so grab
a chair we want to work on our entire
body each workout will be for 30 seconds
long with 10 seconds rest in between and
it's only for eight minutes so get your
body warmed up and let's start moving so
start by placing a chair directly behind
you we want to start with a really
simple workout which is chest squat okay
and it will also act as a warm-up this
workout is great for beginners to check
that your form is correct
okay so place the chair behind you stand
shoulder width apart toes pointed
forward and just place your hands in
front and just gently touch and tap the
chair okay so you want to make sure that
your butt is tapping the chair all right
simple as that touch and tap push your
butt back chest up and face forward only
30 seconds long 15 seconds left if you
want to you can keep your hands directly
in front of you so again always remember
no hunching forward chest up push your
butt back tap and sit with your butt
first all right and rest for 10 seconds
the next workout is going to be a push
up to spider-man all right so again
start in a high plank position as you go
into a push-up tap your knee against
your elbow alright as simple as that to
blow your body knee to elbow good so now
we're warming up and we're working on
the upper body very nice shoe shop
it's all about moving your entire body
that's the whole goal of this workout
good
five more seconds you should start to
feel your upper body good next workout
chest step up okay hence you want to
make sure that your chair is solid okay
we want to do a simple step up okay
Lix down and change the other side good
so step up kick back legs down and step
up good work on those thigh muscles up
down and up very nice okay
tighten your core to make sure that you
are in the center keep going five more
seconds last few more one more and rest
it out now side leg raise place the
chair right beside you step white okay
one leg onto the chair one leg and just
bend
okay this is a really simple side leg
raise ladies to really work on your
inner thighs one leg up and you're
really working on the inner thighs on
your right leg and on your thighs on the
left leg keep going bring it down low
nice and gentle low-impact workouts no
jumping but you will really feel your
muscles working good change side okay
right left leg up right leg and let's go
keep it bent nice point notice if you
want to lower your body even more push
your butt back good push it back nice
controlled movement good again if you
want to just place your hands in front
of you really for your thighs your right
and your left inner thigh working keep
going
good keep going three more seconds last
few more and rest it out this time let's
grab the chair place it directly in
front of you and we want to do lick
kickbacks okay you can even do this on
the kitchen while waiting for your food
to cook so just kick back squeeze your
butt muscles that is the goal okay kick
back balance and squeeze kick back and
squeeze
so just support your body with one hand
of both arms again keep your core tight
kick back squeeze your butt good chest
up do not lean too far forward chest up
kick last to kick and now change sides
alright right leg kick back five more
seconds you can start immediately if you
want to kick keep going kick and squeeze
your gluts very good keep going again
remember while you're waiting for your
food to cook you can even do this at
your kitchen island few more last one
ten seconds left keep going and few more
last three seconds and rest it out next
workout will be tricep dips okay so grab
a chair now we want to move on to our
upper body right Stan just gently dip it
down okay
again remember your body should be close
to the chair if you're doing this this
is wrong okay
buddy close to the chair if you're
struggling then what you can do is just
keep your knees bent and make it easier
beginners this is what you can do as you
progress extend your legs and just keep
dipping last three more seconds
last one and rest it out single Lake
lunch left and right okay
so legs up step forward okay we want to
work on our right leg first and really
just launch down this is also an
advanced move okay so you really have to
find your center of gravity and really
only work on your right leg
good keep lunging keep going relax the
left leg work on your right thigh it's
okay make sure you're taking a step wide
enough for you to really feel your right
face working and now just rest it up
shake it out a little bit we want to
change side all right so left leg up
right leg up left leg forward and ready
let's go down and up good keep going
down and up
very very nice whew balance find your
balance
halfway there keep your left leg strong
you will always find that one side will
be stronger than the other side ten more
seconds don't rush the workout last few
more keep going down and rest calf
raises okay
a lot of you have been wanting cuff
exercises so again place your chair in
front of you this is just a support
raise your cuffs up and down gently up
and down okay
just very gently up and down squeeze
right at the top small movements but you
will feel your calf muscles working
always remember the squeeze right at the
top wait for one second bring it back
down good squeeze if you want to you can
even release and find your balance good
keep going small calf movements and rest
it off final workout knee tucks grab the
chair
sit on the chair we want to work on our
apps okay so let's go knees in release
and in good make sure you're sitting
right at the edge of the chair okay in
and up good knee tucks in and out do not
rest your body against the chair it is
just to give you a nice support keep
going last ten seconds one last workout
and you will have a great day ahead nice
few more and rest it out well done guys
that was your eight minute chair workout
which you can do first thing in the
morning okay
it is a really simple workout it's a
really gentle exercise you can even do
this when you are in your hotel room
traveling or even at work so the whole
goal of this workout is to get you
moving is to get your blood flowing and
for you to have the energy to have a
good day you can't start with eight
minutes and as you progress increase it
to two or three more sets and make it a
full workout remember to keep it
consistent and do this workout at least
three to four times weekly okay
be sure to like this workout video share
with your friends challenge your friends
to do this total body chair workout let
me know how you get on in the comments
below and don't forget to subscribe to
my youtube channel for a lot more
workout videos workout challenges and
guys please turn on your notification
button so that you will get notified
every time I share a new video all the
best